no son raras las crisis energéticas en
china pero ninguna es comparable a la
actual que además llega en vísperas del
invierno cuando mayor es la demanda
energética 20 de las 31 provincias
chinas han adoptado restricciones
severas de electricidad lo que afecta no
sólo a la vida cotidiana de millones de
personas sino también a la actividad
empresarial muchas fábricas han tenido
que cerrar otras alumbran con velas o
han comprado generadores de gasóleo la
consecuencia lógica es que la actividad
manufacturera ha caído a sus niveles más
bajos desde la pandemia de coronavirus
la cámara de comercio de eeuu en
shanghai que agrupa a un millar de
compañías se lamentaba hoy que algunos
de esos cortes de luz se les habían
comunicado con apenas una o dos horas de
antelación lo que les ha provocado la
pérdida de pedidos o el deterioro de
materias primas la crisis explica que
goldman sachs había rebajado la
proyección de crecimiento anual desde el
82 por ciento al 78 % y es previsible
que los problemas de la fábrica global
también se extiendan al resto del mundo
especial cuando empieza la punta de
producción para satisfacer las demandas
de la campaña navideña